[Música]
el presidente del gobierno español Pedro
Sánchez se juega la cabeza después de
anunciar elecciones anticipadas este
lunes tras la derrota el domingo en
comicios regionales Mientras tanto el
líder del partido popular Alberto Núñez
feijó celebró los resultados y pidió el
voto definitivo de los ciudadanos vamos
al análisis de esta noticia con Virginia
rosso doctor en ciencias políticas de la
Universidad de Manchester e
investigadora postdoctoral en la
universidad de de Lisboa también es
especialista en opinión pública y
migración y Europa Muchísimas gracias a
usted por estar con nosotros Virginia
Hola buenas Muchas gracias a vosotros
pues esta es una noticia que nos ha
caído el día lunes y comienzan a darse
los desarrollos quiero preguntarles si
podrían estas elecciones adelantadas ser
una apuesta que eviten mayores pérdidas
para el partido socialista Qué
posibilidades tiene el psoe de
recuperarse después de este golpe
Bueno pues
en principio
la llamada de Pedro Sánchez a las urnas
para empezar nos ha hecho cambiar el
tema de conversación ya no estamos
hablando de
de la pérdida de poder electoral o de la
pérdida de poder autonómico que ha
sufrido el partido el partido socialista
en las últimas elecciones sino que
estamos hablando de las nuevas
elecciones que se van a celebrar
así También sirve este esta este
adelanto electoral para cerrar un poco
las filas dentro del partido y evitar
las críticas internas que se podrían ir
dando debido a la hecatombe que ha
supuesto perder el poder en comunidades
autónomas tan importantes como como la
comunidad valenciana
y para terminar Pues yo pienso
personalmente que esto ha sido como
Pedro Sánchez diciéndole a los electores
si nos han gustado los resultados que
han salido sobre todo a los electores de
izquierda que no han obtenido
representación
voy a dar otra oportunidad para que para
que podáis votar y
y que salga yo y que le dé nada la otra
oportunidad claro claro vemos el
hundimiento de podemos que socio del
partido socialista y Yolanda Díaz ha
formado a partir de ahí su propio
partido sumar pero por el momento no se
alía con podemos podría ahí encontrarse
el capital político necesario para
digamos darle la vuelta a esta situación
desde el punto de vista del psoe bueno
el psoe no puede ahora mismo tal y como
está la correlación de fuerzas no puede
gobernar en solitario no va a poder
gobernar en solitario
salvo que haya un cambio
radical en lo que nos dicen las
encuestas sin embargo además bueno o
además sumar el problema que tienes que
esto le pilla en pleno proceso de
formación No si yo llegara a las a la a
un acuerdo para las anteriores
selecciones este domingo con podemos Y
eso les ha supuesto una pérdida de poder
a toda a todo el a todos los partidos
que hay a la izquierda del partido
socialista pero claro esta convocatoria
de elecciones pone Mucho peso oponen
mucha presión sobre ambos partidos para
que alcancen un acuerdo sobre todo si
tenemos en cuenta algunos datos que han
salido recientemente que dicen que sí
puesen juntos
conseguirían 58 55 escaños mientras que
separados unidas podemos y sumar cada
uno por su lado conseguirían solo 38
escaños esto es un aliciente muy
importante para que en los nueve días
que quedan hasta que haya que
que presentar las candidaturas se pongan
de acuerdo
Pues bien bajo esta presión también
quisiera preguntarle por qué decidió
Pedro Sánchez hacer la convocatoria Tan
pronto y no esperó hasta diciembre Cómo
afecta además toda esta situación el
hecho de que España esté a punto de
asumir la presidencia de la Unión
Europea
Pues en principio
la presencia de la Unión Europea está
prácticamente cerrada y preparada falta
que España asuma la presidencia el 1 de
Julio lo que sí que puede afectar es al
desarrollo de la presidencia si cambia
el gobierno
Mientras tanto además puede afectar
dentro de la campaña electoral porque
Pedro Sánchez ha utilizado Europa como
una base electoral importante y por lo
tanto
lo que lo que puede cambiar es el hecho
de que haya
Bueno hay durante la campaña electoral
española habrá varias
varias
comparecencias del presidente del
gobierno español en foros europeos que
pueden o bien darle muchísimo
muchísimo ímpetu a su campaña electoral
o bien ser utilizados por por la por el
bloque de la derecha tenemos un discurso
el 13 de julio que es en plena campaña
electoral un discurso que tiene que dar
en estrasburgo y sobre todo y más
importante sobre todo para para sus para
sus oyentes es la Cumbre de la Unión
Europea y la celac que se celebra entre
el 17 y 18 de julio
y España se quiere posicionar como un
nexo entre la Unión Europea y América
Latina y el Caribe Virginia si la
apuesta de Pedro Sánchez no resulta esto
podría abrir la puerta a la derecha en
una posible Alianza con la extrema
derecha y han señalado algunos medios
que sería la primera vez que un partido
de extrema derecha estaría en el
gobierno desde la muerte del dictador
Francisco Franco en el 75 qué tan
cercana ve usted esta posibilidad
pues lo cierto Es que no podemos decir
ahora mismo si esto va a pasar o no va a
pasar tal y como están las encuestas
ahora mismo tal y como tenemos el estado
de la opinión pública se tienen que dar
muchas cosas porque el PP tiene un
problema con vox el partido popular
tiene un problema con este partido de
extrema derecha y es que igual que le
suma por un lado le resta en ese votante
que está dudoso entre el partido
socialista y el partido popular ese
votante no quiere esta coalición o esta
esta Unión con un partido de extrema
derecha y por lo tanto se puede ver
tentado a votar al partido socialista si
cree que esta Va a ser una una acción
pero es que además es necesario dentro
del parlamento español contar con otros
partidos minoritarios de ámbito
regionalista a los que vox ha llenado de
manera
increíble durante la última el último
las últimas cámaras y que no van a
querer pactar con el partido popular si
el partido popular va en coalición con
vox por lo tanto le quita también peso
parlamentario Entonces se dan se da
hasta contradicción ahora mismo es
difícil saber
si Box entrará en el gobierno Aunque
ellos han demandado Por supuesto que sí
tienen que apoyar a un gobierno del
partido Popular entrarán en el gobierno
Pues Virginia Gracias por ayudarnos a
adelantar estas previsiones veremos en
unos días qué pasa con las candidaturas
y después con las propias elecciones
Muchísimas gracias es Virginia rosso
doctora en ciencias políticas y que
tenga un feliz día gracias a vosotros a
nuestros televidentes quédense con
nosotros Eh ya regresamos con más de
directo a América
[Música]